The Witcher offers some clues as to its
chronology for fans who are paying close
attention with work you can peace more
or less the entire timeline together
there are still some questions and
ambiguities but the overall picture
works just fine here's what you need to
know viewers don't see the earliest
scenes in The Witcher until the season's
final episode through Geralt flashbacks
we meet his biological mother Vicente
and watch as she abandons Geralt at Kara
Morin where he meets his mentor vesemir
and begins his Witcher training in an
interview The Witcher showrunner Lauren
Schmidt has Rick revealed the Geralt is
already 100 years old by the time
viewers meet him in the first episode
that means that young Geralt scenes must
have happened at the very beginning of
The Witcher timeline of the witcher's
three main timelines Jennifer's origin
story comes first
yennefer looks fairly young when to say
a Biser from her father in Episode two
and all of Jennifers early days happened
before the rest of the main plot we
don't know how long yennefer spends at
school but it doesn't seem like much
hunchback yennefer who should age like a
normal human doesn't show many physical
changes during her studies however
according to his ray yennefer story in
season 1 spans about 70 years after
ascending yennefer spends 30 years in
the court at a turn and another 10 or so
kicking around as an independent
sorceress before the Battle of Sodom
that leaves 30 years unaccounted for
either his Rick had her numbers wrong or
yennefer trains at arethusa for a lot
longer than it seems
Geralt first three adventures take place
next it's not clear exactly how long it
takes Geralt to become known as the
butcher of blumpkin or how long it took
you a skier to make Geralt famous given
the Geralt entire story in season 1 is
about 20 years long in the 12 years
passed between Geralt two visits to
sintra an 8 year period between episode
1 and episode 4 makes sense
we can also surmise the Geralt battle
with the streak ax in episode 3 takes
place about 30 years after Jennifer's
transformation at the Sorcerer's Ball in
Jennifer's timeline king foltest of
tomaría can be seen pestering his sister
anna and the future monarch looks to be
around 10 years old when Geralt meets
him bowls toises in his 40s inada has
been dead for years Jennifer and Geralt
stories in episode 4 see
happen around the same time yennefer
claims that she has been at eight him
for three decades before she decides to
strike out on her own and that's about
how much time has passed for full test
and gerelds timeline in Episode three
further Geralt reputation is firmly
established by the time that he first
enters Queen Helen thise court this is
the first episode that makes it crystal
clear that we're following three
separate timelines in the episode
nilfgaard is a joke and series mother is
newly pregnant in the first episode
though kalantay and i star married
serious 12 years old and nilfgaard is a
mighty military force in bottled
appetites the star-crossed lovers geralt
and yennefer meet for the very first
time courtesy of a Jen and a bottle
enough time passes between bottled
appetites and rare species for geralt
and yennefer to build up quite a bit of
history their bickering references
numerous encounters beyond the one we've
already seen and they seem to have spent
quite a bit of time together
yennefer and yes skeer know each other
pretty well at this point - and they
don't seem to get along which is all
bound to bump into monsters eventually
the crowds feet on you finally series
story brings the three timelines
together with the collapse of Sentra in
the lead-up to nilfgaard attack jennifer
joins the Brotherhood of sorcerers to
discuss the impending invasion while
Geralt goes directly to Sentra to try to
rescue ciri in fact Geralt was in
central in ciri fled the city
unfortunately chol anthe had locked him
in a dungeon to keep him from running
off with Cirie at any rate series
storyline in episode 1 and geralt and
yennefer plots in episode 7 happened at
the same time according to his Rick
series story in the witcher's for a
season unfolds over the course of a
couple of weeks ciri meets Dhara
shortly after escaping centra and only
spins a little bit of time in the
refugee camp before the nilfgaard
attacks a few days later she enters
broken LAN forest after a few nights in
broeckel on the Doppler disguised his
mouse sac takes ciri and Dhara away ciri
discovers the deception and frees
herself soon afterwards from there
ciri fins for herself she tries to pawn
off her jewelry for cash and is
ultimately offered a home by a kindly
woman with a house in the woods all of
this unfolds in the time between gerelds
second visit decentraland episode
seven and his arrival at the former
refugee camp in Episode eight by the
beginning of episode eight much more all
three timelines are in sync while
Jennifer and her fellow sorcerers are
fighting nilfgaard at sodden Geralt is
fighting for his life on the back of a
merchants carts in Syria is waiting in a
cabin with the merchants wife all of
this happens about a week after ciri
fled the refugee camp when Geralt first
meets the merchant the man is cleaning
up the bodies that nilfgaardian army
left behind the episode also takes place
over a couple of days the sorcerers
arrive at sodden and prep their defenses
in the daytime the ensuing battle begins
at night takes the whole next day and
ends just before dawn the morning after
the battle is when Geralt and ciri meet
for the first time
yennefer disappears after using a ton of
magic to channel fire at the
nilfgaardian army but she's probably not
gone for good as the season ends
Jennifer is the one everyone's talking
about how is Jennifer check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you